I finally found sheets that are long
enough to cover my mattress and my box springs.
These sheets went viral a few months ago,
and I'm so happy I finally got my hands on them.
Our bed is very tall,
and our mattress is really thick,
so I chose the extra deep set of sheets,
and I love them.
Right off the bat,
I noticed how soft they were,
and it wasn't like a hot,
flannelly, soft feeling.
It was more of a smooth,
luxurious, soft feeling,
if that makes sense.
And like I said,
I love how deep these sheets are.
They cover the entire bed.
I didn't have to yank or pool to
try and get them to fit.
And I will say that
my husband is very picky about sheets,
and he loves them,
so they're kind of a big deal around here.
Head over to Amazon and grab yourself a set.